Joe Scarborough over at the televised
mental institution known as MSNBC he had
faucian and fauci I I keep saying it I
cannot believe this guy has not just
disappeared like dude you were the
highest paid guy in the federal
government you're getting the highest
pension of anyone in the government
even if you think you did a good job
just go away for a while but he can't
stop he's addicted to the media and here
is fauci on Joe Scarborough yesterday
right and and it's ever evolving and
evolving very quickly it's just like
vaccines people will still go ah you you
got coveted even though you got a
vaccine what we didn't we didn't know
none of us knew you didn't know exactly
how those vaccines would impact the
virus
um but we've learned quite a few things
about the vaccines too there's a very
resilient virus it's a very durable
virus and and it morphs very quickly so
so develop a vaccine and it still helps
in a positive way but it doesn't wipe
out covered can you explain what we've
learned about vaccines over the last two
years
well there's one very very obvious fact
that is born up by very solid data Joe
we know that if you compare
unvaccinated people with vaccinated
people with regard to hospitalizations
and death there is an overwhelming and
dramatic difference of a greater
likelihood of hospitalization and death
among the unvaccinated and as the months
went by if you compare vaccinated but
not up to date with boosters with people
who are totally up to date on boosters
there's still a difference in the sense
of vaccinated and updated boosted people
do much better with regard to severity
of disease that's an open and shut case
there's no doubt about that actually
there is a lot of doubt about that there
are no studies that prove what he just
said right there he keeps saying it over
and over and this is what every
celebrity and every politician kept
saying when they would get coveted after
they got faxed and boosted I'm just so
happy I got backs and boosted because I
have lesser coven there are no studies
on that and Robert Malone who's the
inventor and owns more patents on mRNA
technology than anyone he believes that
that the vaccines are actually degrading
people's immune systems which is why
we're getting this Resurgence in
shingles and a whole bunch of other
usually dormant diseases that a lot of
people have so he made that up he
noticed he doesn't reference the study
he doesn't tell you any of the numbers
but he keeps showing up Savannah he just
keeps showing up and we should just
expect he's just gonna keep showing up
Dr fauci is one of the biggest criminals
that I've ever seen in my life and the
fact that he's not in jail right now is
horrific because to be quite honest with
you the way that he handled uh
information to the American people over
the past two years was horrific and
again he really did put so many people's
lives at risk by stopping preventative
treatments because he wanted to wait for
the vaccine and again too you can go
look at the FDA fact sheet that was
updated for the modernity vaccine that
says that myocarditis and pericarditis
are indeed a side effect of this
vaccination for some reason we're barely
Hearing in the media that hey heart
effects are an issue you can go look at
countries that have the highest
vaccination rate like Australia or New
Zealand and you can see that they're
having an unusual uptick in deaths if
you'd like more sane takes on our insane
World check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live round tables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell